so how do
I
oh
War okay good morning everyone um we
start today with Scott Senter who has
done a lot of pioneering work on the
machine learning side of circuits
introducing various circuit
formalisms came up with the idea to
extend them to continuous variables Etc
and out of the many things that he has
done related to circuits he has chosen a
few highlights which I guess will be
around continuous variables and their
applications in machine learning so I'm
eager to hear the story from
C
okay thank you for the morning crowd for
coming out um hopefully this is worth
your time um okay I I I want to start
off with some uh controversial
statements to warm everyone up um and
some questions um do we have any flat
earthers
here no okay we have any do we have any
discreet
earthers ah yes okay people who view the
world as M
Minecraft um okay well uh what I hope to
convince you today is that
occasionally resisting that urge to look
at that continuous function and to
discretize in 10,000 pieces right
occasionally you want to resist that
because you get a very elegant solution
if you can crank through all the math in
closed form right and obviously for
continuous functions we can't do that
all the time I'm going to show you today
lots of cases where we can actually do
it and get Exact Solutions and compared
to some massive discreation they are
Compact and elegant and you might want
to consider them okay so I I you know
this talk which may be different the
rest of the week you know has continuity
in it right and I'm gonna say how do I
extend this decision diagram framework
to deal with
continuity this is the example I we
start off with right I think most people
in the audience are gonna know uh have
heard of or no hidden Markov models
right so here's a hidden Markov model I
use B for Boolean X for continuous uh
State and O for continuous
observation uh and all I've done here is
just show you a bunch of you know if if
if the X and EOS are continuous right I
can show you a bunch of continuous
functions right to represent the
conditional observations and conditional
transitions right the prior next could
be uniform it's pretty easy if you look
at the probably observation oi what
censored at XI symmetrically if the
sensor is not broken zero but the sensor
is broken one you get an asymmetric
response to
XI so you know most people work with
discreet hidden Mark models there's no
reason I couldn't obviously Define a
continuous one right C filtering is
doing this all the time with galaxin in
that case so the question is how would I
uh you know what sort of conditional
inference would I get uh um so if I did
look at the probability 01 given uh
whether sensor is broken or not right I
get sort of these two uh posteriors over
the observation one right one looks Gan
other looks not galaxian right thanks to
this asymmetry here right but I I can go
2D right I can look at the probability
of X5 given o1 where X5 is on the x axis
and no one's on the Y AIS right the
probability is the Z axis right um so
I'm looking here right and you know if
you look down at the top right it's
actually sort of a piecewise function
thanks to our uniform and you're looking
at this and you're
saying what's that function you know
exactly what you're saying
um and the thing is you know you might
look at this and say oh mixer Gans well
I don't know I I I don't think I'd use a
mixer Gans when I have these sort of
hard piecewise boundaries right I mean I
don't see Gans here right in fact this
function actually isn't too complex um
uh but it's you know but a mix of gin is
sort of gonna make mistakes in
approximating it right what I'm going to
show you in this talk is how he can
crank through these operations right in
closed form and still to this day I mean
aside from lat work right uh in this
area right no one sort of really does
these sort of operations this h mark mod
inference you know beyond the Galaxy in
case Beyond special cases in closed form
okay so I'm GNA show you how we can do
this in some cases not all cases
obviously okay so so how do we attain
exact close form Solutions right and
we're going to work with symbolic
representations you know occasionally I
have to sell that to an audience I don't
think I have to sell that to this
audience which is great um you know but
I usually say you know think Mathematica
right not not lab right what can we
crank through
symbolically okay so the the main
ingredient that I'm going to need right
so so if you're discreet your main
ingredient is your table right if I'm
continuous my main ingredient is this
case function okay um and so I'm going
to read off you know in in in if these
constraints hold right then I get this
value and I'll call the com constraint
to value a
partition and I realized this is
actually backwards how the
mathematicians us usually write it and
this just comes from historical
historical notation in the field but
just read it as if this constraint holds
you get this value and so
on um okay so we look at this function
down here right we can see it sort of
has you know piecewise linear boundaries
right and linear hyperplanes within
those boundaries so linear cons value
make take this interactive uh what sort
of constraints and value expressivity do
we have
here
can't go on till
someone someone gives me the
answer the question well so here we have
linear value do we have linear
constraint value
here or is it
different constraints the pieces look
linear but what about the values are
they
linear well okay there there there are
some artifacts of how it's drawn but
it's suppos to be flat topped right so
this is linear constraints constant
value
okay one okay what the constraints of
here
sorry cindric yeah so so so so quadratic
inequalities right greater than or less
than to get these Rings right and then
within this quadratic boundaries right
quadratic boundaries I would get a
quadratic function right so quad
quadratic in value yeah just give you a
a geometric sense for what we're doing
here okay so you know in all of
graphical model inference in all of
decision- making sequential decision
inference mdps pomdps which are sort of
my uh bre and butter uh and in
optimization right we're just going to
do we're g to work with some function
class right in this case the case
statements and we just have to do you
know a bunch of operations we have to
multiply functions add them maximize
minimize over them integrate over them
right and uh optimize right if x is
continuous optimize over these functions
right and and the question is right how
do we do all of these operations in
closed
form not to the arch I mean not you
obviously can't do this for any
arbitrary fi andf right but in pretty
expressive cases you can do this pretty
interesting cases I would
say okay so now I know a few people in
the audience seen this talk before so I
apologize to you this is for the folks
who haven't seen this before um how
would I sum two cases right the results
going to be a case statement because I
want to say closed form first question
is how many partitions right would go in
the resulting case
statement four Okay C say four C right
okay so we just take the cost product of
all the conditions right and then each
condition we get the sum okay obviously
the same thing works for times does the
same trick work for Max
well if I wanted pols say in the
functions which I will want a lot of
this talk right then plus and Times
Obviously give me pooms but the max
right uh would would give me Max of F1
and G1 right and so the question is do
you think I can do the max in closed
form without inserting a Max
there can I get this in case form where
f and g are polinomial and still get a
case statement where the resulting
functions are
polinomial values are polinomial anyone
to see the
trick goes into the condition yeah Ma
Max is a peie wise operator right it
creates conditions right so I can say if
I'm in the case where F1 S one holds
true and F1 is greater than G1 right
then obviously f1's maximum right um and
so on so on and you know usually at this
point in the talk someone's like yeah
yeah yeah you can do this notationally
Scott but good luck making it work in PR
practice and that's exactly the case
right like this stuff is going to blow
up
horribly if you try to crank through it
with the case statement and that's why
we have decision diagrams in this talk
which are going to come
up
okay okay so we we will we will address
this okay and this is sort of like this
is a a key result going back to 2012
it's one of my favorite results and and
again apologize apologies for those
who've seen it but for those who haven't
I think it's pretty cool how would I
inte rate out the variable X in this
function assuming that the fs and the fs
could contain the variable X right I can
kind of I I can always rewrite my if my
if
my uh constraints my case statement are
disjoint and exhaustive right then I can
always rewrite uh the case statement as
an indicator summation right just G to
pick out the right value okay and by
this just always be an integral from NE
to infinity and so what I can do here
now I've got a a sum and integral right
uh is I can swap them now I had a I had
a great student go off to Princeton and
he he worked on XDS actually got a best
paper on on work on XDS and he sends me
an email back he's like actually I took
this math class there are some
conditions you know under which you can
do this and some conditions under which
you can't so okay you can't always do
this uh you can do it a lot
um and right so the nice thing about
going uh to this form right is that this
this outside sum right is just the the
circle plus right this plus operator
showed you we just to figure out how do
you do this inner integral right focus
on that so we integrate the inner
function from Nega Infinity to Infinity
right here's our constraint here's our
function if we didn't have the
constraint integrating a polinomial is
Trivial right these constraints just get
in the way so what how could I leverage
these constraints here to rewrite the
problem i' really like to rewrite it in
a way that I got rid of the constraints
in front of the function anyone see
it like what are the constraints
actually saying about
X you know X is greater than negative 1
x is greater than Yus One X is greater
than Max Nega one y one the constraints
are giving me bounds right so here's a
lower Bound in blue right the upper
bound right is in red and the green but
it has no impact on this on this
integral right because uh it's
independent of the integram okay so I
can I can rewrite this right so so the
lower bound is sort of the max of
negative one and Y minus one right
remember the max operator was a case
statement upper bounds the Min of Zed
and y + one it's a case statement right
and I can uh now rewrite this integral
right from x equals lower bound to Upper
bound right uh over UNC constrained F
right and I pull out the other green
constraints out front Okay so okay so
now my simplii the problem um there's a
few more things that you have to be
careful about when you do this they go
here right the key thing is the upper
bound lower bound are symbolic and we
have to evaluate this thing so here's
here's the integral here's po integral I
got to evaluate the upper bound and
lower bound because the upper bound and
lower bound are these case statements
right how would I evaluate
this
well the nice thing to note here is
that you know these are polinomial right
and polinomial are just plus and times
and I know how to do plus and times I
know how to cube X right uh I you know
upper bound times times itself three
times right same for the lower bound so
I can plug in these case statements in
the polinomial and this is the resulting
evaluation it's all purely symbolic
right and that was one partition right
and then I I do this remember I I do do
it for each partition I sum them all
together right and and and and at the
end of the day right you can compute all
this in closed form right so as long as
I had sort of these piz polinomial
functions right I can work through the
exact
inference right and and and this is also
cool right because I I can I can take
the expectation that any polinomial
right I can also compute means variances
skew cryosis and all these things right
in closed
form okay so again back to this problem
right this is the Machinery I just
showed you right you've got plus and so
you got times for The Joint of the
graphical model right you got a lot of
marginals for the inference right but I
can do all that in closed form and this
is a piecewise polinomial right a a
mixture
Gans okay the key thing is just yeah
everything here's a case statement you
just crank through everything
and now but in this is in theory right
again you will not you you will not
solve it yet by the simplest problems
you work with a case statement because
you're going
typically 100 operations right and
that's a lots of cross product cross
product operations okay and and I'm
always asked about sort of worst case
complexity on inferencing graphical
models and I think and I I've actually
got rejection uh because I didn't bound
the inference in a graphical model in
terms of tree width right but you know
what you realize the tree width sort of
goes out the door when you're continuous
because is when you're discrete your
complexity depends on number of discrete
variables right you can bound that right
when you're continuous uh you can't
bound how how
complex uh your functions get right even
on Cassie was saying this last night
even in a Oneal function right can be
arbitrarily complex okay so really when
you're looking at continuous inference
or inference continuous graphical models
what you care more about is number of
operations right and all I know is that
in the absolute worst case right my
could be exponential the number of
operations it's not very hard to get
right hundreds of operations and
therefore like worst case like you're
not going to do this right and and I
think that's why people didn't do this
before because you need more than just
the math okay but I'm gonna introduce
decision diagrams right to really
mitigate this Force case complexity
doesn't solve it right these things get
big right but it really allows me to
crank through things I could not crank
through previously in closed
form yes please
operations like in the previous example
can what do you exactly mean by number
of
operations sorry what do you exactly
mean by number of operations okay right
so I write down uh The Joint right with
a product and so that's going to be if I
have in cases then that's n minus one
multiplications right then I have a
bunch of integrals to do right to
compute these marginals but the integral
is not just one operation right if I go
back here
yeah this interal said oh you got you've
got to take some mins of some functions
some Maxes of some functions you've got
to do case operations for all the
polinomial evaluations right so this one
integral suddenly blew up with a huge
number of operations and again back to
the
previous all these operations typically
involve this sort of cross product
blowup right
so you know even a simple graphical
model like
this will involve hundreds of Elementary
plus times uh
operations and you know each operation
worst case exponential well you know is
sorry sorry each each each operations
are giv me cross product right so after
you know in operations I get some
exponential number of in potential case
partitions so so given
given a representation you are able to
compute a bound on the number of
operations a
PRI yeah I mean but it's it's it's such
a large number the EXP of that number is
you in Practical even for the smallest
graphical models
yeah but there is hope right uh there's
a lot of structure in these functions we
just have to exploit that structure
right and that's decision diagrams come
in okay um just who who is aware of bdds
and adds and the reduce and the apply
operation
ah it's unusual for an audience okay so
I'll go very quick here right because
you know what I'm talking about um okay
so I have so let's let let's I'm gonna
go discreet right and I'm gonna try to
I'm then gonna try to sort of lift this
up to the continuous level and say what
happens um so uh here is a function over
uh three discrete variables a b and c uh
if the values are just 01 and they were
Boolean it would be a bdd right if they
were continuous it'd be called an ADD
the alge diagram right I think everyone
knows you you know to to to to turn you
know you you never build these tables
directly right you know that you're
you're gonna incur an exposal blow up
you always sort of build your decision
diagrams from functions right from from
operations but anyways if I want to
start with sort of um uh this table I
can first convert it to a tree right and
I can exploit a lot of context specific
Independence for example in the case
that x a a equals true I'm not dependent
I'm not dependent on p b
but furthermore I can compress this
right the tree can be compressed and I
do that by going Bottom up I'm merging
leaves right and once I merge leav I
realize oh you know these these uh sub
diagrams are identical right I to do
some simp simple hashing I get to merge
those right and voila right you get the
add as long as you have a fixed ordering
from rout to
Leaf okay and not only do I get
compactness in the representation right
over tables certainly and over uh even
over trees right I also get uh
efficiency in the operations now here's
where I mean a lot of the circuit folks
you know don't typically do operations
some do but but but most don't so here's
here's where you you know um may need to
Quick refresher right how would I how
would I multiply these two diagrams well
again just thinking recursively I'm
going to branch on a being true right
and then I get into these two
subfunctions but zero times any
subfunction right is going to be zero so
that's pretty easy okay take the other
Branch right I get down here to
B these two diagrams I can't do it
exactly so or immediately so iue
branching on the earliest variable okay
now I get these two functions I branch
on
C and so
on and you know you can Bal these apply
operations sort of quadratically in the
number of nodes in the input because I'm
only ever looking sort of at all pairs
in the worst case fact you don't look at
all pairs but that's the worst case uh
bound
um okay so I I can do the operations
efficiently so for this to be efficient
you need to have the the same variable
that's the reason you need yeah yeah
yeah yeah so I do need I do need a fixed
variable order here you can you can
relax these things right I think some
people in the audience can can relax the
variable orders but I typically would
just stick with
this is that is that do that does that
hurt you a
bit
okay
okay so that's on discreet right uh
large fraction of the audience knows
that but let's see how would how do we
get to the
xdd right um you know uh it's just an
extension of the algebra decision
diagram so here's a case statement right
what would that look at look like as a a
decision diagram you know where my
decisions
now right uh they're actually sort of
inequalities right it's not very hard to
imagine that I can just put each each
inquality decision right and then I can
figure out what sis diagram would look
like for
that okay so nice thing about you know
the xdd is that it's you know um uh for
like an exor right it would be sort of
linear in the number of cisions right
just like for the uh the bdd and and the
add whereas if you look at the case
right or even the tree right it'll be
it'll be
exponential so you know you you get the
same compactness guarantees that you
would get from uh the bdd and and the
add
um you but things you know but one thing
you don't get in the bdd and add that
you get here is that now now these
decisions can interact right now they
are linear linear inequalities they
could be more expressive but I tend to
work with things that I can actually
work with with LP solvers and so on so I
tend to stick with linear decisions and
now decisions interact and that that
introduces some uh issues so let's just
go through how I would start to extend
the operations that I have so let's take
the max of these two two diagrams right
I'm going to do the same thing I'm G I
have a I have an ordering over decisions
now right so the first decision my order
is y greater than zero I'm going to
branch on that being true right okay no
only next decision is X x greater than
zero right and so okay so y z x than
zero what's the max of X and Y I don't
know but I can compare X to Y and say
well if x is greater than y right I get
X otherwise so what's interesting with
the XDS is that you you know I I can
fill in all the branches not you get
some nice compactness in the max right
you always sort of get this very
redundant sort of uh shared structure uh
which is way better than the case
operations um but you know what
interesting note here is that your
operations will introduce new decision
variables you haven't seen before
um so usually I pen them at the end you
can be my students have told me well you
you can be more clever sometimes and
save space but uh okay so we can still
do these things like like the max
operation close form uh but let's look
at some some complications right and
decision actually can get out of order
so let's say that a priority in my whole
you know uh I have disordering of
decisions right clearly once I introduce
this Max decision at the leaf right I've
gotten my decisions out of order right
so that's one case in practice where you
get decisions out of order I'm going to
show you another case and then show you
how to fix
it so what means out of order so you
mean like you see y x and then X and Y
what do you mean ah okay okay right yeah
so we don't okay in the continuous case
we don't order on the variables
themselves okay very very good question
uh we order on the decisions right so
the order of decisions is you have to do
this test and then this test and then
this test
right so
um it is very interesting can I order on
variables I'd like to think about that
but currently we just order on decisions
right so we get a new decision we always
just put at the end of the list it's a
bit lazy but it gives us an ordering on
decisions and for linear inequalities I
can always look at two linear
inequalities and tell you whether
they're the same same decision or not so
the left order is the one you wanted to
do process and then you had a different
order is this what you yes great okay
yeah great please Slow Me Down folks I
don't you know if I lose you then it
makes the next few slides uh bit painful
um yes okay so I did
and I violated this order right because
remember the max introduces this new
decision okay so that's one case where
we introduce decision out of order
another you know another case when I get
into mdps uh I'm gonna do lots of
regression lots of
substitution um and in this case uh you
know I started with again the same order
right and this function I substitute
right every Z with Y
okay this was in order y greater than
zero came before X great Zed right but
now that I put Y in for Zed right now my
X great than y right which should come
first comes after Yer than zero okay so
again a second case where you can get
decisions out of order does anyone
know for a beer a
night um or lemonade uh does anyone know
uh the easiest way to fix ordering
issues
without doing node
rotations don't worry I'll okay a beer
for
me um okay so this is a nice trick right
you can implement it in uh in five
minutes um and uh so let's let let let
let's say Zed was out of order we is
back to the sub
diagrams right but let's assume
recursively that the sub diagrams were
ordered so I only just have to get Z
into the right point in these sub
diagrams
right well I can always do these
operations here right I can do the apply
operation of Zed times this right
because this was ordered and this is
trivially ordered that's GNA be ordered
right I can also do the reverse right so
I so I take the inversion of Zed right
multiplied by the false Branch right
this is ordered right because I can do
you know if I do an apply operation on
two diagrams the result is ordered by
doly operation of two ordered diagrams
result is ordered right so so
everything's ordered here ordered sum
ordered and voila I've got Z in the
right place and I've only done uh the
apply
operation um so it's a quick trick you
do it in five minutes uh and it nicely
makes a lot of use of caching right to
uh reorder things um so it can be
actually more efficient sometimes than
than node rotations which don't
typically
cache okay so all I want to point out
here um sorry for the pain is that you
know you get these interactions between
variables you get things out of order
you just have to be aware of this and
fix them because the correctness of
these diagrams depends on the fact that
you have the
ordering okay now minimality is a pain
um I have a journal article in 2014 that
has not been submitted yet uh nine years
later uh it's like 70 pages I will
happily forward you the draft if you
want to know more about more about e EX
um but what what has really killed me
from you know kept me from uh submitting
this article like when I submit on XDS I
want to have the answer I want to have
the theory that says this is what you
should do there's nothing else but what
kills me here is is the fact that you
know maintaining minimality is
incredibly hard right if I look at this
case right well if Y is greater than
zero right and X is greater than zero
then we know obviously X Plus y cannot
be less than zero right we cannot reach
this Branch here right and there have a
number of trivial ways to figure that
out strain solvers and to print it out
right okay so we um and what's what's
what's annoying though is that when
you're doing the reduce operation right
the reduce operation takes a non-conical
diagram reduces it to a a well in the
bdd case and add case canonical form
when you do the reduce operation on xdd
uh sometimes things blow up because on
some branches you destroy structure and
then things blow up um so this really
makes it hard to say there's a minimal
canonical form there's definitely not a
minimal form right might be canonical
according some some some definition but
canonical is not minimal as far as I can
tell so anyways you get these
interactions and we can deal with them
right this doesn't prevent me from doing
the operations saying the result is
correct but it PR me from saying that
the result is minimal and obviously if I
go beyond linear decision it's really
hard to work with in
practice um but here here's a case that
uh one of my Brazilian colleagues uh
pointed out to me right so what's the
minimum what's the minimal diagram here
can you rewrite this diagram in a way
that's
smaller well you look at the
function
right just plot this function so it's
only function of X right you'll see a
sort of Step function the steps a cur
six and eight right you don't even care
about
so diagram here right is going to be
actually this
function um and so if I did rotations so
there I can't prune anything here right
you sort of verify that all branches are
reachable here um so I can't prune
anything I could rotate some nodes right
or reorder and then prune and then get
this but how would I know what to
reorder you know and in what order to
get these prings so again all I want to
say is I don't have any good answers to
what the what the canonical diagram is
uh nor the minimal diagram is uh and if
one existed how you would find it um and
I can I mean the counter examples to me
indicate that especially in the case of
reduced blowing up um you can't have
both minimality and canonicity okay but
again uh so do we just say Okay whoops
you can't do this let's just give up on
this line of research no everything's
the apply operations are still correct
right all I'm saying is that it may not
be
minimal
yeah so typically you would defin
minimality with respect to given order
of the decisions so here the issue that
you are changing the order of decisions
and you are getting a better one um but
the decision order could be X less than
x greater than seven uh X greater than
eight xra in the six right this this
diagram is is consistent with this
order
remember I'm ordering
decisions so I can go this one this one
this one right and this one's still
consistent so yeah great great great
question anyways so this is why after
nine years this journal article is
unsubmitted I just I don't know what to
say here is there anything know known
about equivalence checking of P wise
pooms and I feel like the problem here
is not necessarily minimality but
canonicity so you can reuse subcircuits
even if they're not min
right as they blow up and I don't know
maybe there's some theory about
probabilistic equivalence checking up
pwi functions or I don't
know yeah okay I need I'm here to talk
to the theorist right to give me some
inspiration right after nine years how I
can attack this so let um yeah so let's
discuss this uh after the talk um I
would love to have some
insights where are we um technically I
have five minutes I think uh
so now right okay in short though I can
do plus times everything I should ort on
the case statement I can just do on the
XD and it is correct right it just may
not
be minim more well yeah minimal or or
canonical but it's it's correct right so
I go back here and I replace everything
with the
X and voila right this is an xdd right
and again I couldn't do this as case
operations but I can do it as as as XD
operation
you're actually looking at sort of you
know you know a plot for my toolkit uh
that's doing
this
okay so I mean the FD right it allows
now allows me now to work with these uh
mixed streak mixed continuous functions
you know and I didn't have you know I
didn't have to discretize I I didn't
have to harm any continuous variables
right in Computing this right I can
comput it completely to completely
continuously didn't have didn't have to
discretise makes me happy
makes some of the discreet earther happy
um okay
so right the XD enables all the previous
inference right um I just want to say
when you're doing decision making you do
Maxes when you do optimization you do
Maxes when you do map inference you do
Maxes whenever you do Maxes you create
in continuous spaces right two functions
two hyperplanes I Max them I get a
piecewise result and then the one thing
I realized is you know when you're when
you go to Contin space you have to be
willing to work uh um you know uh with
these peie wise functions right um
they're first class citizens that's sort
of one of the key things to deal with
xdd gives you methods right to work with
that pwi
structure okay I have to go very quickly
here I just want to say you know that
was inference but I also do decision-
making optimization and I want to run
you through some quick
results uh and then I'll take questions
um so I mean I've been very interested
in solving uh mix of street continuous
mdps um lot mdps like this one I've got
some trash can robot right in uh in
position XY and I want to get to the
goal and the goal is are a rectangular
region you know and um that should be in
happen there uh and you know this is
like a really trivial problem and I you
know my my colleagues would discretize
this like we don't know how to solve MP
continuous variables we're going to
discretize this I'm like no like you
know let's let's be symbolic let's let's
let's try to like do a bell backup right
through moving x to the right two
positions you got of realize it just
takes this reward and it and it
just so imag I I I I I I I can move
right to I can move up to right this are
my two actions right my reward is this
just getting into this goal
region so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to regress going to work backwards
through time and say well if I if I was
here in the in the next time step where
would I have been in the previous time
step if I had done move X2 well that's
just a translation right and in fact
translations are just are just
substitutions in the in the in the case
or the XD form right A Q function is a
translation right for each action right
and then the max is the max over those
and it's just gonna be this piecewise
function but you know I don't have the
time to go through all the Machinery
here uh I want to point out that when
you have when you have these continuous
problems uh you can crank through the
solutions symbolically and again because
I'm doing uh in my bell and Backup Plus
and times uh and I'm maxing Q functions
right the XD is ideal here I get
everything it's a nice pie wise
form here's inter case imagine this was
my transition right uh X Prime equals
some polinomial y Prime equals some you
know fairly you know ugly function with
a log in it
is it possible to regress to work back
in time and say well if this was where I
was in next stage where where was I
before by move nonlinear action
right you this case statement is Trivial
what does this thing look like is it
easy to compute looks like a pain but
the interesting Insight is when you're
doing a backup you're actually just
substituting I'm substituting X Prime
with this function and Y Prime with this
function everything in the case form I
can figure this out trivially right I
know some what I have here um and so
it's very easy to work with nonlinear
continuous bases right in mdps right
and even better imagine these are two Q
functions right as case statements XS I
can still Max them right um because uh I
can do the max operation and so what I
did back in UI 2011 uh is I um I showed
how you can crank through
nonlinear transition continuous NPS and
solve them in closed form right now if
you're nonlinear you can't really prune
things out things don't stay compact uh
but you uh but you can uh compute these
things in close form um and that was
sort of probably one of the major
results of my
career okay so all I want to say is you
do your B backup for those who know it
writing everything here is xdd you know
what I can do in close form thanks to
the xdd okay so that's decision-making
uh I also have worked on maximization as
well like useful for inventory and
operations research and so on I can work
through the Max and close form uh for
the for PSE linear cases in fact that's
equivalent to solving a parameterized
mix mixed linear program
um I'll come back to this later if
anyone wants to see the math for it um
let me go into the
last but you know what's what's nice
here in the MVP case is I get my value
functions syic form I get my policies
what should I do right oh you're here
you know you fall into this position in
the X State space I should move y10 you
fall in this position should be y equals
10 right I get
symbolic uh I get symbolic value
function I get Sy symbolic policies
right and you know for the RL folks like
why would you discretize and why would
you do you know massive sampling under
gpus right with a few algebraic
operations allow you to comp exactly
what you want to do right
just Mo on up so I I I I I I I can I can
do a lot of compression of these
diagrams right I can compress them to
make them smaller and still within some
Epsilon
err um and finally I just want to get to
one key
result skip through
optimization but this was sort of the
most recent result here
um uh I've been looking at some machine
learning problems right specifically
this one called smart predict optimize
where it says you want want to learn
your uh learn your predictor in light of
decisions that you're making and what
you get is sort of this bilinear
interaction between the learning weights
the weights you're learning and
decisions you're making and this problem
has has a bilinear structure and when my
student and I were looking at this
problem we said well if you fix a
y you fix a y you clearly get a linear
function
right um so and then but if you if you
collapsed out if I mend out the Y first
you actually get a pie y linear function
this happens in always happen in in the
in in the in the in the in the bilinear
case because basically uh for different
regimes of X there's different y's the
points that might be the minimizer right
and so these pieces that you get are the
points where you switch over one piece
to the other so what we realize is the
bilinear problems if you collapse out y
right allow you to reduce it to a uh
piece wise problem which can be encoded
as a mixxed linear program
right and so we're actually doing
symbolic variable elimination where
exactly what we did on our hidden Markov
model right limiting variables right
we're going to actually Min out a y here
collapse this down to fun to a p wise
function over X and solve it as a mix
line program right I was very proud of
this in i22 we showed you can exactly
solve uh this smart predict optimized
problem which sort of been an open
unsolved problem machine learning since
2017 right just by symbolic methods you
can convert one OPP opposition problem
to another class is more easily solvable
right by deflating it by projecting out
variables and symbolic methods give you
those tools okay so let me just recap
here right what I what I've done in this
talk is I've defined a calculus for Psy
functions right I've shown you how the
first operations work I didn't show you
how the observation works I can do that
offline right and then to work
efficiently with the this thing I def
find the case the X to represent the
cases right and then you can you can
work in continous mixed stre graphical
models you can do planning exactly solve
planning control and or problems
including inventory control solve it in
closed form right uh
constructively right and new paradig for
optimization right many many problems
that were previously thought unsolvable
I can convert to other problems with
symbolic manipulations and show they're
solvable with Al shelf
software okay so you know simple
in conclusion right symbolic P twice
calculus plus XD right gives you really
expressive hybrid inference optimization
and control just try to resist that
effort to discretize and some beautiful
things right can pop out of that okay
thank
you guess we have time for one
question
so uh back to the minimal problem so uh
what's the problem like given a decision
diagram and a variable order what is the
complexity of finding the minimal
decision diagram or because exist one
right
um so I mean the the the bdds and and
the ad and the for the bdd and the add
you can you can
very you know very easily prove right uh
that you can obtain for a given order a
minimal diagram which is canonical right
any function that's exactly the same
will will will have exactly that uh
conical structure um if I apply those
same reduction operations to the
xdd the XD can blow up in size right and
offline I can tell I can tell you why
that happens so clearly to sort of have
a
what I think would be canonical right to
not have parts of the diagram that that
that that are
unreachable uh you sacrifice minimality
right so the two no longer coincide I
think G was
saying focus on
conicity right you can't have both right
uh so he was saying focus
on kity but but I I guess my my my my
problem is these these beautiful results
for BS and 8s just don't translate to
the ex case right I can't have
minimality in cany together so what
definitions do I use which one do I
want but the second example you showed
is also prob for bdds there could be a
different variable order under which you
can prod some notes but you know that's
something
that but I didn't have to change I
didn't actually I didn't have to change
the order there actually so and I didn't
have to change the order yeah that's
that's a problem
than Sol my problems I will buy you a
beer or lemonade all right thanks again
Scott I guess while Robert sets up
there's a random Connection in the
program where I think maybe